bonsoir voici les titres de ce journal
le ministre de l'intérieur jean pierre
chevènement se trouve dans le coma
depuis plus de 24 heures mais son état
s'améliore lentement vient d'annoncer le
l'hôpital du val de grâce
un avion de la swiss air s'est abîmé
dans l'océan atlantique
nous allons voir après ces images de
l'hôpital du val de grâce où se trouve
actuellement monsieur jean pierre
chevènement et puis je voulais vous
annoncer ce deuxième type puisqu'un
avion la suisse hier s'est abîmé dans
l'océan atlantique au large de la
province canadienne de nouvelle écosse
il y avait 2 129 personnes à bord il n'y
a pas de survivants puis troisième site
ce sera la rentrée scolaire pour les
petits et les grands nous le verrons
dans quelques instants
l'état de santé de monsieur chevènement
s'améliore lentement ce sont les termes
très récent d'un communiqué diffusé peu
après 28 heures 15 par le médecin chef
de l'hôpital d'instruction des armées du
val-de-grâce à paris le ministre de
l'intérieur se trouve dans le coma
depuis plus de 24 heures victime d'un
arrêt cardiaque
le ministre avait été admis au val de
grâce pour y subir l'ablation de calcul
dans la vésicule biliaire monsieur
chevènement a fait une allergie au
produit anesthésiant contenant du curare
son coeur s'est arrêté n'est pas reparti
spontanément mais à l'issue de plusieurs
dizaines de minutes de massage tout au
long de cette journée des nouvelles à la
fois alarmiste et rassurantes se sont
succédé benoît duquesne vous êtes au val
de grâce ce soir on est toujours prudent
mais plutôt un petit peu optimiste
oui vous venez de le dire c'est vrai que
les médecins sont très très prudent
encore il dit simplement que ils se
sentent modérément raisonnablement
optimiste par rapport à 7 cm état de
santé de monsieur chevènement dont vous
venez de le dire
il s'améliore lentement c'est le texte
du communiqué officiel publié ici au
val-de-grâce faut dire que toute la
journée on a donc attendu que ce soit à
matignon au ministère de l'intérieur et
bien sûr ici au val-de-grâce attendu des
nouvelles de cet état de santé il y a eu
l'épousé de monsieur chevènement qui est
venu lui rendre visite accompagnée de
l'un de ses fils il y a eu monsieur
georges sarre le président délégué du
mouvement des citoyens
et puis pour le gouvernement s'était
charge osselin le ministre délégué à la
coopération qui s'est rendu dans la
chambre
ce service de soins intensifs où il se
trouve toujours
et puis en fin d'après midi on a vu
venir ici le médecin chef de l'hôpital
le médecin général yves cudennec qui est
venu donc confirmer avec cette présence
vous allez entendre les termes de
l'amélioration de santé de monsieur
chevènement
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur a
été hospitalisé à l'hôpital
d'instruction des armées du val-de-grâce
pour y subir une intervention
chirurgicale programmée sur la vésicule
biliaire
il a été victime au tout début de
l'année saisie d'un arrêt cardiaque très
probablement d'origine profite à la
fille lactique les mesures de
l'animation adéquates ont été prises
immédiatement
il est actuellement placé en service de
soins intensifs et son état s'améliore
lentement un nouveau communiqué sera
diffusé dans 24 heures
il est réactif mais la famille de
monsieur chevénement a souhaité que je
n'en dise pas plus dans vous comprendrez
que je respecte son les choses
s'améliorent lentement mais sûrement
nous sommes très modérément optimiste
pour l'instant y'a pas de pronostics sur
l'accident l'accident est beaucoup trop
récent pour qu'on puisse porter un
pronostic aujourd'hui faut se donner un
peu de recul dont vous constatez cette
prudence il est réactif ça veut dire
tout simplement de la pression n'a pu
savoir par ailleurs et bien que par
exemple et ça c'est de très bon augure
monsieur chevènement réagi à l'énoncé de
son nom qu'il a bouger les paupières
qu'il a réagi aussi en bougeant les
doigts autrement dit il est en phase
ascendante de sortie du coma mais il s'y
trouve toujours
ce qui veut dire que par exemple au
ministère de l'intérieur dans son
entourage proche on se montre là aussi
très prudent on constate effectivement
cette amélioration et on s'en réjouit
bien sûr après les nouvelles très très
alarmante qu'on a eu toute la journée et
aussi les détails qui sont venus
s'ajouter sur cette ré aminé cette
animation très lourde qu'il a dû subir
tout cela donc on enregistre mais on
attend bien sûr d'en savoir plus si
benoît et puis à l'hôtel matignon on a
fait annoncer que monsieur chirac avait
signé un décret qui prévoyait l'intérim
de monsieur chevènement c'est monsieur
jean jacques queyranne son secrétaire
d'état qui assurera cet intérêt pour
l'inciter à vous êtes à l'hôtel matignon
aujourd'hui
ya quelques instants je crois le premier
ministre aussi a fait une déclaration
je crois que ce qu'il faut dire c'est
qu'ici à matignon on tient à bien cadrer
des choses et je dirais surtout à ne pas
dramatiser jean jack queyranne reste
secrétaire d'état à l'outre-mer il
assure simplement l'intérim pour suivre
les affaires en cours dans un ministère
particulièrement difficile avec des
dossiers particulièrement délicates
comme par exemple le dossier corse mais
pas question en tout cas on le dit bien
ici à matignon pas question de
remplacement jean-jack queyranne
d'ailleurs qui a été reçue tout à
l'heure par lionel jospin et c'est le
premier ministre lui même qui a tenu à
s'exprimer je vous propose tout de suite
avec je suis affecté profondément par
cet accident qui s'est produit à
l'occasion d'une opération
j'espère que les choses vont aller dans
le bon sens seront progressivement en
attendant la continuité de l'état doit
être assurée et en même temps nous
devons tout préparé pour l'accueillir à
nouveau quand il reviendra ce que je
souhaite et j'ai donc proposé au
président de la république l'intérim
soit assurée par monsieur jean jacques
queyranne secrétaires d'état à
l'outre-mer qui était délégué auprès de
jean pierre chevènement
j'ai eu l'occasion de m'entretenir ici
même tout à l'heure dans ce jardin
derrière avec lisa chevènement je
connais également depuis longtemps et
j'espère que nous aurons progressivement
de bonne nouvelle à tous voilà je vous
remercie de 800 pieds carrés
voilà pour les dernières déclarations
officielles tantôt l'hôpital du
val-de-grâce cas à l'hôtel matignon
voyons maintenant l'aspect médical
cette opération de la vésicule biliaire
se pratique très fréquemment on la
qualifie même de banal mais ce qui l'est
moins c'est l'anesthésique art tout
anesthésie présente est en effet un
risque
voici les explications sur cette
opération et la procédure d'anesthésié
utilisé pour monsieur chevènement
reportage benoît thevenet bernard
ronfler l'anesthésié générale c'est un
peu comme le décollage ou l'atterrissage
d'un avion
les deux phases les plus dangereuses
sont l'endormissement et le réveil les
mêmes gestes les mêmes appareil ultra
perfectionné sont employés que ce soit
pour une opération compliquée où une
intervention beaucoup plus courantes
comme l'ablation de la vésicule biliaire
la vésicule biliaire c'est un petit sac
d'une dizaine de centimètres
situé juste en dessous du foie l'habile
qu'il contient facilite notamment la
digestion des graisses
parfois les calculs se forment à
l'intérieur de la vésicule il faut
opérer une intervention qui se pratique
généralement sous coelioscopie
le chirurgien opère par de petits trous
grâce à une caméra au moment de
l'anesthésié jean pierre chevènement a
fait ce que l'on appelle un choc
anaphylactique une allergie aux curares
d'une extrême gravité
un pourcentage de cas très faible je
pense que c'est de l'ordre de un sur
vingt mille interventions ou anesthésie
l'enjeu a fait un sur 20 me en est saisi
il peut se produire qu'il existe un
accident inattendu à la suite de cette
réaction
l'organisme libère des toxines qui
attaquent les organes vitaux
si le coeur repart c'est grâce au
massage cardiaque mais le cerveau a
souffert c'est le commun le foie lui ne
parvient plus à remplir sa fonction
d'épuration
pire il génère d'autres produits
toxiques qui continuent à entretenir le
coma un véritable cercle vicieux si le
foie ne reprend pas le dessus
le cerveau peut être endommagée
irrémédiablement
bonsoir monsieur vous êtes le professeur
karam sa milice est chef du service
d'anesthésié réanimation du chu bicêtre
je veux dans des explications simples
pour comprendre autant que l'on puisse
le savoir ce qui s'est passé au
val-de-grâce concernant le vis de
l'intérieur
cette anesthésie set ça se passe comment
quelle est la procédure pour quand on
n'endort un malade devant le maladie les
vus en consultation de l'ecstasy et
maintenant c'est obligatoire en france
ensuite le patient est endormi une sonde
est posée dans ses voies respiratoires
pour l'aider à respirer artificiellement
et on lui donne suffisamment de sommeil
et de calmants contre la douleur pour
que le chirurgien puisse opérer
alors là on a utilisé du curragh
évidemment c'est pas des cures art pur
c'est un c'est un mélange c'est un
dosage
quel est l'effet du curare le curaray
relâche les muscles permet à
l'anesthésiste de mettre cette somme
dans ses voies respiratoires et permet
aux chirurgiens d'avoir un relâchement
des muscles qui lui permettent d'opérer
en tout confort peut-on dire que c'est
un accident faut faire attention c'est
pas un accident cardiaque c'est un
accident de type allergique
c'est ça absolument c'est un accident de
type à les ingénieurs comme un
empoisonnement comme un empoisonnement
mais qui n'est pas dû à une dose
excessive c'est à dire même une petite
quantité chez quelqu'un de sensible peut
déclencher un cataclysme qui s'appelle
un choc allergique
je m'étonne un petit peu c'est à dire on
ne peut pas prévoir cette réaction
énergique
nous essayons de le prévoir lorsque le
patient a eu déjà des incidents avant
dans ces anesthésie précédente
nous pouvons le savoir lorsqu'il est
lui-même très allergique asthmatiques
nous pourrons prendre des précautions
mais ces accidents peuvent survenir chez
quelqu'un qui était parfaitement bien et
pour lequel on avait aucune présomption
de survenue d'accidents accidents
fréquents 1 pour 3000 anesthésie à peu
près et à ce stade là aussi aussi
développé non justement peut-être le
message que l'on doit retenir c'est que
dans trente accidents de ce type qui se
passe tous les jours en france il y en a
qu un seul pour lequel l'anesthésiste
peut avoir des difficultés à faire sa
réanimation facilement un coma réactif
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
c'est à dire que lorsque l'on parle aux
patients il répond de façon coordonnée
ça peut aussi être quand on lui fait mal
alors maintenant je pense que benoît
duquesne disais tout à l'heure il réagit
à la voix c'est à dire vous testez la
voile
le l'épiderme comment ça c'est à dire au
minimum on pose des questions et on
demande aux patients des réactions s'il
réagit ce qu'il réagit à la voix c'est
un stade de coma très léger ça derrière
aj quoi ils bougent les yeux il fait ce
qu'on lui demande où parfois il réagit à
la voix de façon un coordonnées mais au
moins il y as entre la voix et lui une
réaction
et pour nous c'est quelque chose de
plutôt bons pronostics il réagit à la
boisse il réagit pas la voix vous
continuer les tests on lui fait mal et
on voit s'il réagit à la douleur et si
il ne réagit ni à la voix ni à la
douleur qui n'a pas de réaction c'est
naturellement beaucoup plus péjorative
ce qu'on appelle un coma à réactif exact
un privatif alors allons jusqu'au bout
dans cette réflexion
les séquelles les lésions sicile le
cerveau n'est pas ne reçoit pas
l'oxygène nécessaire en cas de massage à
peu prolongé alors plus le massage a été
long plus l'arrêt cardiaque prolonger
plus que le risque c'est qu'elle est
important parce qu'ils payent d'oxygène
qui est arrivé au cerveau mais on peut
avoir certaines certains cas où il ya eu
un massage prolongé où le patient peut
récupérer totalement sans connaître le
cas précis de chevènement vous pourriez
prévoir une durée de de retour à une vie
normale
oui ce que nous disons souvent aux
familles c'est avant plusieurs semaines
il n'est souvent pas possible de se
déterminer donc je crois que dans ce cas
comme dans d'autres il faut rassurer
attendre que le temps permettent une
récupération éventuelles merci monsieur
2 de toutes ces précisions
alors aujourd'hui notamment dans les
milieux politiques il ya eu beaucoup de
surprises beaucoup d'inquiétudes et puis
en même temps la fin de cette journée un
petit peu de propos rassurants nous
avons voulu reprendre toute la
chronologie de cette journée les
commentaires et les réactions des hommes
politiques notamment dans la cour de
l'hôtel matignon
reportage alban nicosie carole commun
toute la journée bruisse des rumeurs
divers ont circulé autour de matignon où
se tenait la réunion interministérielle
au gré des allées et les venues
la dernière en date vers 17h30 madame
chevènement est reçu par le premier
ministre pour un entretien privé la
publication d'un bulletin de santé étant
soumis à l'autorisation de la famille un
peu plus tôt le garde des sceaux
elisabeth guigou avait fait part de son
amitié envers jean pierre chevènement
pratique personnelle
il apprécie beaucoup la coopération
qu'on a réussi à installer entre nous
alors qu'on a l'habitude de dire entre
ministres de la justice et mises
intérieur c'est quelquefois après
difficile entre nous pas justement
j'espère qu'il reviendra très vite sur
l'état de santé de jean pierre
chevènement lui même quelques
indications sont données en milieu
d'après-midi par le ministre de la
coopération
ils veulent mieux pour le moment
les bus a ensuite ajouté une certaine
note d'optimisme qui domine en fin
d'après midi ici sans que l'on puisse
fixer une durée à l'absence du ministre
de l'intérieur
voilà qu'il ya eu aussi beaucoup de
manifestations de sympathie à belfort la
ville de monsieur chevénement je vous
rappelle que selon le dernier communiqué
de l'hôpital du val-de-grâce l'état de
santé du ministre de l'intérieur jean
pierre chevènement s'améliore lentement
nous retournerons à l'hôpital du val de
grâce avec benoît duquesne à la fin de
ce journal
il n'y a pas de survivants après le
crash de l'avion de la compagnie
swissair a un gros porteurs mcdonnell
douglas l'avion qui assurait la liaison
entre new york et genève s'est abîmé en
mer de l'océan atlantique à 10 km au
large des côtes canadiennes de la
nouvelle écosse il y avait 2 129
personnes à bord les causes de
l'accident sont encore inconnues
commentaires gérard griesbeck
plus de quinze heures après la
catastrophe aérienne il ne reste que des
petits débris
plus de 200 personnes participent aux
recherches dans la zone de l'accident
aborde plusieurs navires de la marine
ainsi que des bateaux et des
hélicoptères de la garde côtière
canadienne
petit à petit on récupère des morceaux
de fuselage des sièges ou des bagages de
passagers
tôt ce matin on a retrouvé des corps 18
exactement n'y a donc pas de survivant
229 morts dont 136 américain 41 suisse
et 30 français dans l'après midi les
enquêteurs donné quelques informations
les plongeurs sont sur place sont aidés
par les responsables de la sécurité du
transport aérien
ils coopèrent pour tenter de retrouver
au plus vite la boîte
l'avion a donc quitté hier au soir new
york pour genève où il devait atterrir
ce matin à 2h48 exactement une s'écraser
au large du canada
après avoir signalé de la fumée dans le
cockpit et des problèmes techniques
l'appareil un md-11 de ce type avait été
mise en service il ya sept ans il était
en parfait état de marche selon la
compagnie swissair il avait même subi
une vérification complète
inial l aéroport de roissy un centre
d'accueil a été mis en place pour les
familles des français 31 français
figurant parmi les victimes en suisse à
genève dès l'annoncé de la catastrophe
la compagnie swissair donné quelques
précisions sur les conditions de
l'accident et tentait de renseigner les
familles concernées
reportage didier guyot jean claude
martin nous pouvons confirmer que
l'accident survenu tôt ce matin un autre
avion m des elfes en route de new york
vers genève a coûté la vie à 215
passagers et 14 membres d'équipage
il est 16h30 les familles des passagers
du des séances de swissair a couru ce
matin genève n'ont plus aucun espoir
il n'y aura pas sûr visant une cellule
d'accueil a été mise à leur disposition
toute la journée une cinquantaine de
psychologues et de médecins ont tenté de
le retenir
ned avait que des représentants des
communautés religieuses le temps une
ambiance très crûment il accueille les
familles sont passés ensemble chacun
tranquillement bien sûr il ya des crises
d'hystérie 2.0 difficile pour les
psychologues de trouver les mots quand
la mort survient aussi brusquement une
mort lointaine avec des corps que l'on
n'a toujours pas retrouvé première
journée est une journée où on n'arrive
pas à réaliser
on ne sait pas ce qui s'est passé
n'arrive pas à croire ce qui s'est passé
c'est que lorsque les événements du lin
du lendemain du surlendemain confirme
que malheureusement ce n'était pas un
cauchemar que c'était la réalité que la
confrontation se fait de plus en plus
dur quant aux causes de la catastrophe
enquête ne sait que débuter l'avion mis
en service en 91 avaient été entièrement
révisée
tout était normal avant le jour fatal
aucun rapport de pilote ou technique n'a
été établi concernant cet avion qui
aurait pu amener à faire des rêves et
des tchèques
donc il était un parfait état de vol
lorsqu'il a quitté genève hier matin
demain matin de vols spéciaux de zurich
et de jeunesse seront affrétés pour les
familles à 5 et se rendent sur les lieux
du drame
on en saura sans doute plus une fois
qu'on aura récupéré certains débris mais
les travaux de recherche sont très
compliquées au large d'halifax car ils
s'étalent les débris s'étale sur plus de
10 km on a commencé à relever certains
éléments du fuselage première partie de
la rentrée scolaire en france pour les
collèges ce fut calme plat affirme un
communiqué du ministère de l'éducation
dont tout va presque bien cependant le
syndicat national de l'enseignement
secondaire accusait le ce matin le
gouvernement de chercher à tout prix à
faire des économies au détriment des
enseignants côté enfants la rentrée
s'est déroulée de façon plutôt classique
alors voyons d'abord les tout petits 2
ans c'est vraiment petit alors faire
connaissance avec la classe maternelle
c'est une grande aventure
voyez le reportage à nantes de nathalie
moisan et bernard connor
pourtant le chagrin du premier jour qui
a dit que la rentrée le meilleur moment
de l'année pour les plus beaux tic c'est
d'abord une rupture avant tu accompagnes
yuma pour éviter les larmes on soigne
accueil et pour cause dans cette classe
les enfants n'ont que deux ans l'école
des tout petits en zone d'éducation
prioritaire
un choix pédagogique qui donne des
résultats ici depuis 20 ans il ya un
développement surtout du langage un
développement de la socialisation
l'apprentissage de la vie en grand
groupe des règles de vie sont plus vite
apprises ils ont conscience d'appartenir
à un groupe ça qui est important
il ya un développement de notre site et
il ya beaucoup de choses qui évoluent
très vite on s'aperçoit que
dans des milieux plutôt défavorisé
disons d'origine ouvrière notamment les
enfants qui ont été scolarisés à deux
ans ont d un meilleur développement
langagier au cours des deux années
suivantes que ceux qui ont été
scolarisés qu'à trois ans 80 % des
enfants de ce quartier vont à l'école à
deux ans pour les paroles avantage est
double vous savez qu il faut beaucoup de
comprendre pour qu'il joue bien
beaucoup et par rapport à la crèche
quels avantages bas question la
scolarisation à deux ans une bonne
solution donc à condition que l'école
ait les moyens d'accueillir les enfants
correctement ce n'est pas le cas partout
selon un sondage publié ce matin par le
parisien la grande majorité des
collégiens apprécié leur professeur et
qualifie la rentrée de bons moments à
passer sans doute les enseignants du
collège pablo neruda à aulnay sous bois
dans la seine saint denis ne sont ils
pas aussi catégorique à la suite des
mouvements de revendications des
enseignants à la fin de la dernière
année scolaire
le gouvernement a dégagé un milliard de
francs pour des postes d'enseignants
d'éducateurs et d apport matériel dans
ce département de seine-saint-denis
mais dans ce type d'établissement comme
le collège pablo neruda où la population
scolaire connaît aussi des difficultés
sociales et familiales
l'argent ne suffit pas reportage
stéphane haumant ian stress
entrée en 6e dans un établissement de
1000 élèves qui par est immense sous la
pluie il y aurait vraiment de quoi
déprimer pour les petits nouveaux du
collège pablo neruda
mais pas du tout le principal fait
l'appel on oublie les vacances sans
regret ce collège est l'un des trente
établissements classés cette année zone
d'éducation prioritaire en seine saint
denis
la zec donne droit à des moyens
supplémentaires et à des primes pour le
personnel un conseiller d'éducation en
plus quatre nouveaux enseignants des
classes seront allégées mais les
manifestants du printemps dernier reste
vigilant on n'est pas entièrement
satisfait par le plan de rattrapage on
pensait vraiment avoir une assistante
sociale à temps plein il n'y a pas et ça
ça nous que ce mot crémant aux élèves de
l'établissement violence échec scolaire
font partie du quotidien
ici 40% des profs demande chaque année
leur mutation
le plan triennal de claude allègre ne
résoudra pas tout le collège est au
coeur d'une cité qui cumulent les
difficultés sociales des quartiers oui
quand tu m'as dit que tu étais une
ancienne non francophones et dernier
rang dont un petit peu de mal à
prononcer encore les noms le collège ne
peut pas être sorti de cet environnement
il va falloir forcément résoudre les
problèmes hors de nos murs
en parallèle de ce qu'on essaie de
résoudre ici on ne peut pas y échapper
huit professeurs attendus ce matin sont
déjà pointés absents si l'effectif n'est
pas complet dès lundi les enseignants
menacent à nouveau de se mettre en grève
deuxième journée du voyage de monsieur
jacques chirac en ukraine principale
préoccupation aujourd'hui du chef de
l'état sa rencontre avec des enfants de
tchernobyl
le président de la république notamment
accompagné du secrétaire d'état à la
santé bernard kouchner a visité un
institut baptisé les enfants de
tchernobyl des enfants irradiés lors de
la catastrophe de la centrale nucléaire
de tchernobyl c'était il ya douze ans
cet institut est animé par une
association française qui a voulu
recenser tous les enfants encore victime
des irradiations
ainsi cette petite fille née quatre ans
après la catastrophe
reportage véronique sainte olive jean
cornu douze ans après l'explosion les
conséquences de la catastrophe de
tchernobyl n'en finissent pas galina
huit ans elle est née quatre ans après
le drame
cette petite fille a un cancer de la
thyroïde est aujourd'hui faute de soin
adéquat en ukraine
elle s'apprête à partir se faire soigner
en france depuis 90 dans le centre de
kiev une association créée par une
française marie laurence simonet avec le
soutien de bernard kouchner alors
secrétaire d'état à l'action humanitaire
des pistes et assure le suivi des
victimes
dix mille dossiers dans ce centre le
seul de son espèce qui récupère comme il
peut le matériel trop démodé pour les
hôpitaux français
est ce que la population ont si bien
là-bas à pripiat qu'ici à kiev était au
courant personne n'était au courant et
la population ukrainienne s'en doutais
un peu mais bon il pouvait pas
s'imaginer quelle est l'échelle de cette
catastrophe
ici on a aidé on continuera de le faire
c'est évident par contre sur la france
pour prendre en charge la médecine de
l'ukraine mais c'est parce qu'ils
demandent non plus jusqu'à présent on a
toujours fait face mais c'est vrai même
problème vous devez d'abord trouver
l'argent et ensuite je m'affaire venez
un enfant cet après midi jacques chirac
a rencontré les enfants déjà soigné à
paris
des paroles d'espoir pour victor
anastasia et les autres tchernobyl
plus jamais ça sur tous mobilisés pour
que ça ne puisse pas se reproduire
puisse pas se reproduire la première
chose à faire c'est fermé et ce sera
fermée mais pour produire l'énergie qui
lui est nécessaire à l'ukraine doit
achever deux autres centrales
or devant les difficultés actuelles du
pays la banque européenne renâclent à
accorder les 3 milliards de dollars
promis alors avant de type étienne
jacques chirac s'est engagé à tout faire
pour accélérer le processus
en russie la bourse de moscou a encore
enregistré une baisse importante - 25 %
pour la monnaie russe le rouble ce qui
évidemment n'arrange pas les affaires
des consommateurs les prix des produits
alimentaires et de consommation courante
sont à la hausse et puis surtout les
clients des banques veulent retirer au
plus vite l'argent qui les y ont déposé
reportage à moscou de nos envoyés
spéciaux dorothée olliéric et franck
brisset ils se pressent par dizaines
devant les guichets fermés de l'une des
plus grandes banques de moscou ils
veulent leur dollars le rouble ils sont
en colère à cause des policiers des
clients décident de sortir pour nous
parler
vous filmez là et bien là direction de
la banque de nos vies rien elle ne nous
explique rien on va manifester et vous
vous viendrez avec nous vous êtes
humains non à quoi sert notre président
mais qu'est-ce qui vous vous le découper
en petits morceaux dans cette banque
notre argent
ce nantes retraite ses maigres économies
pour payer mon enterrement
ce matin il fallait 13 roubles pour
acheter un dollar ce soir il en faut dix
sept
la monnaie russe a perdu plus de 50% de
sa valeur en quinze jours la bourse a
atteint aujourd'hui le plus bas niveau
de toute son histoire
et la valse des étiquettes dans les
supermarchés laissent les plus pauvres
totalement abasourdi à 80 ans katarina
touche une retraite de 400 roubles à
cause de la dévaluation et ne touchent
plus que 200 roubles soit 100 francs
c'est trop cher les frais en double est
comment va faire maintenant
qu'est ce qu'on va faire est ce que vous
voulez faire des stocks des quoi vous
parlez des stocks c'est pas possible je
voulais acheter quelque chose ici mais
je ne peux pas vous avez mieux les prix
huile
il est passé à 20 roubles la bouteille
c'est un crime a finalement katarina
n'achètera qu'un peu de sel dans ce
magasin où pourtant rien ne manque
les produits sont importés le stock
s'écoule doucement seul l'huile est
aujourd'hui introuvable ici
comment expliquer tout ça j'en sais rien
est ce que je le droit de parler à je le
crois oui eh bien je voulais parler du
premier ministre turc omer dit il dit
qu'il veut faire quelque chose parle
mais jusqu'à présent rien fait et je lui
crache dessus
le droit de parler c'est bien tout ce
qui lui reste et elle ne sait pas encore
que la russie vient de vivre un nouveau
jeudi noir
eux non plus après moscou
belfast en irlande du nord le président
américain bill clinton est venu saluer
les efforts de ceux qui tentent de bâtir
la paix trois semaines après l'attentât
d'omagh qui avait fait 28 morts
bill clinton et son épouse ont parcouru
les rues de la ville touchée par le
terrorisme
et puis ce matin à londres et à dublin
les parlements respectifs britannique et
irlandais ont adopté de nouvelles
mesures antiterroristes en république
démocratique du congo le bilan des
affrontements dans la capitale à
kinshasa la semaine dernière serait de
plusieurs centaines de morts dans le sud
du pays les rebelles ont consolidé leurs
positions pour la première fois depuis
le début du conflit nous avons pu nous
rendre dans le sud du congo dans la
province du katanga
parmi les troupes pro bell qui venait de
s'emparer de calais nier près du lac
tanganika reportage laurent boussier
philippe ghislain quelques images volées
sur l'aéroport de quel aimiez dernière
ville du katanga passé entre les mains
des rebelles congolais du blanc ce
missile mitrailleuses lourdes et soldats
faisant le signe de la victoire
ici les traces de combats sont encore
bien visibles
l'aéroport situé à quelques centaines de
mètres du lac tanganika a été le seul
point de résistance des militaires de
laurent désiré kabila
la troupe de camilla voulait défendre
l'aéroport mais se fait pas c'est
difficile paulo de retracer les prendre
entre de l'alpa il est avec nous et
tristan salaire de prof cette roue la
route qui mène en ville et quasiment
désertes seuls quelques véhicules
chargés de soldats circule à vive allure
dans la rue principale beaucoup de
magasins sont fermés une grande partie
des habitants fuient et se cachent
encore dans la brousse
les soldats sont partout omniprésents
ils patrouillent sans arrêt certains ne
sont que des enfants
d'autres sont plus âgés mais tous n'ont
qu'une idée en tête
kabila doit partis qu'il le veuille ou
pas il doit partir nous combattons pas
la population
nous combattons pas les troupes 10 14
non mais kabila doit partir et il bâtira
qu'il ne veuille pas la population elle
est beaucoup plus réservé elle ne se
sent pas proche des rebelles depuis leur
arrivée elle reste sur ses gardes
et si les combats de la semaine dernière
n'ont fait officiellement que trois
morts civils les pillages eux ont été
beaucoup plus nombreux les menaces
l'arrivée à ces craintes
il n'y a pas eu de cours bien il ya eu
des balles qui sont passés un à travers
la ville mais il n'y a pas eu de
terribles tout était calme après une
heure a été calme lorsque des vols hors
caméra on nous parlera même de violent
sans que l'on puisse vraiment savoir
s'il s'agissait de soldats fuyant la
ville où des rebelles y entrant les
rebelles qui pour essayer de se faire
accepter n'hésite pas à punir pour
l'exemple
celui-là est entré par effraction dans
un appartement châtiment public et
quelques jours de cachot
en laissant quelques journalistes venir
académies et les rebelles ont réussi à
prouver qu'il tenait militairement le
nord du katanga ici malgré les combats
qui auraient lieu à quelques dizaines de
kilomètres et les craintes de la
population
la situation semble à peu près calme en
israël le pays est paralysé par une
grève du secteur public à la suite de
l'échec des négociations salariales les
syndicats israéliens ont déclenché une
grève suivie par 300 mille personnes
trois cent mille employés du secteur
public donc rentrée des classes retardé
et gros désordres notamment à l'aéroport
ben gourion
selon un rapport de l'onu la population
mondiale s'accroît moins fortement que
prévu dans les années 60 tout laissait
craindre une explosion démographique
nous sommes dans une phase de
ralentissement de la natalité de
vieillissement de la population
c'est l'un des aspects soulevés par ce
rapport de l'onu c'est aussi le
changement de mentalité des femmes
notamment dans les pays du sud en quête
valérie gaget frédéric bonnet venu d'un
village isolé aux portes du sahara ces
femmes marocaines ont marché plusieurs
heures pour rencontrer les employés de
ce planning familial itinérant elles ne
veulent plus autant d'enfants que leurs
mères ou leur grand mère comme elle des
millions de femmes à travers le monde
veulent désormais choisir la taille de
leur famille elles y parviennent de
mieux en mieux
sauf en afrique où la fertilité commence
à peine à baissé après l'explosion
démographique des années 60 les
politiques menées pour réduire la
natalité ont porté leurs fruits
les femmes ont aujourd'hui deux fois
moins d'enfants que leurs mères
l'élan démographique est donc en train
de se ralentir
mais attention du fait des taux de
fertilité très important atteint par le
passé
la population mondiale va continuer à
croître rapidement le cap des 6
milliards d'habitants sera dépassé l'an
prochain et les estimations hautes ou
basses montre une courbe ascendante
jusqu'en 2050 au moins vous savez
qu'actuellement
chaque année
la sueur mondiale augmente d'environ 80
millions tessin alors à ce rythme là on
estime que l'hypothèse la plus probable
est qu autour de 2050 on arrive à des
6,50 encore de la population ça passe et
qu'on arrive à peu près à 9,4 milliards
jamais sur la planète les jeunes n'ont
été aussi nombreux on recense plus d'un
milliard de 15 24 ans mais parallèlement
la population mondiale est aussi en
train de vieillir
la proportion des plus de 65 ans devrait
doubler au cours des 50 prochaines
années dans les pays développés ce
phénomène est déjà largement enclenché
et aux alentours de 2015
on devrait commencer à compter plus de
vieux que de jeunes dans la population
totale les pays riches s'inquiètent des
effets de ce vieillissement sur leurs
économies
car pour équilibrer les régimes jusqu'en
2025 il faudrait reculer l'âge de la
retraite à 67 ans en europe occidentale
74 ans au japon
une solution peu engageante pour
s'assurer des lendemains qui chantent
les radiologues sont en conflit ouvert
avec le gouvernement qui a imposé une
baisse des tarifs de radiologie mais les
radiologues ont quelque peu modérer leur
menace de suspension des campagnes de
dépistage du cancer du sein il précise
maintenant que cette suspension est
provisoire et n'aura aucune conséquence
sur la santé des femmes
reportage eric masi et pierre laurent
constants
elle est attendue c'est la seule action
de santé publique de cette envergure en
france chaque année 300 mille femmes de
50 à 69 ans bénéficient gratuitement de
la campagne de dépistage du cancer du
sein et dépistage financée par les
conseils généraux l'assurance maladie et
les radiologues l'annoncé par le
gouvernement d'une baisse de 13% de
leurs tarifs à choquer ses spécialistes
ils ont donc décidé de suspendre leur
participation à la campagne de dépistage
une décision sans précédent qui a
provoqué des réactions indignées ya
beaucoup de femmes dans ce pays qui
malheureusement ne peuvent pas avancer
les sommes nécessaires pour passer des
mammographies et le tiers payant est là
la campagne de dépistage était justement
contre fait pour surmonter cette
inégalité
c'est pas une attitude compatibles avec
la déontologie médicale
les radiologues affirme avoir voulu
faire un geste fort symbolique mais se
défendre de mettre en jeu la santé de
leurs patientes
de ce côté là je suis prêt affirme le
dépistage continuera en termes de santé
publique nous en reporteront la charge
sur l'assurance maladie et nous ferons
de sorte que des femmes n'aient rien à
payer
martine aubry se dit consterné et pour
bernard kouchner il ne s'agit que d'une
histoire de gros sous ou les médecins
prennent les françaises en otage même si
les radiologues se disent prêts à
négocier c'est pour l'heure le blocage à
venise ouverture ce soir de la 55e
mostra là où l'on montre où l'on expose
des films et des oeuvres
cinématographiques un lion d'or de
venise est en jeu mais on aura noté
cette année tous les paradoxes d'un
festival de cinéma qui tend à la fois de
proposer des oeuvres exigeantes et de
sacrifier au star system avec la
présence de vedettes américaines
reportage à venise pascal deschamps
christophe ferron
chronique d'un débarquement annoncé
casquette vissée sur la tête steven
spielberg part à la conquête de l'europe
avec un nouveau film événement c'est à
la mostra de venise fleurons du cinéma
européen que les succès américains de
l'été un coast désormais sur le vieux
continent
s'il n'y avait pas des gens comme
spielberg la mostra mauvais ce serait un
désastre car ici on compte sur les stars
américaines en ou hors compétition pour
faire le spectacle
tom hanks en ouverture de niro en
clôture mais aussi michael douglas
george clooney au type carré la mostra
vivra au rythme des rumeurs de leur
arrivée et à leur départ
cette année ça s'annonce bien avec
l'arrivée en masse de grands acteurs
américains
ça nous permet de faire de la photo pas
exclusive bien sûr mais on n'a pas tous
les jours l'occasion en italie de
photographier de telles pointures un
festival presque prisonnier de sa
vitrine
on en oublierait presque que venise
c'est avant tout une compétition qui a
consacré les plus grands auteurs
d'aujourd'hui 19 films concourront cette
année dont trois films français une
sélection d'excellente facture il n'y a
pas une vaste thématique
j'ai pas choisi les filles parce qu'il y
avait quelque chose qui au moins cette
année l'année passée était différent
mais il y a eu tendance du l'autre qui
dans notre succès la présence énorme des
femmes dans les films qui ont retrouvé
la place qu'une femme dans la société
paradoxe encore une telle affiche en
fièvre chaque année la croisette
rien de tel à venise ici le public peut
accéder aux projections en achetant son
billet mais les touristes ne sont pas
venus pour ça
en voyage de noces le cinéma non non non
on est juste venu visiter la ville en
vendant dès ce soir hommage à sophia
loren
c'est son mari carlo ponti qui est venu
chercher le lion d'or de l'actrice
convalescente
la mostra n'en finit pas de rêver de ce
temps où les stars venaient d'italie
tout autant que de paris ou de
californie
et à ce stade du journal nous allons
rejoindre benoît duquesne qui est en
direct devant l'hôpital du val-de-grâce
benoît est ce que l'on peut rappeler
effectivement les dernières informations
livrées par le corps médical de
l'hôpital de grasse concernant le miz et
intérieurs absolument ici vous le savez
tout est calme au val de grâce mais il
faut attendre alors on sait que jean
pierre chevènement en tout cas son état
de santé s'améliore lentement c'est le
terme officiel du communiqué on sait
qu'il est réactif autrement dit qu'il a
réagi à l'énoncé de son nom
on sait qu'il a bougé les doigts on
s'écrit à bouger les paupières tout cela
ce sont des signes encourageants pour
les médecins ça veut dire qu'il est a
priori en phase de sortie de coma mais
il s'y trouve toujours et contenu de la
rééducation qu'il a de la réanimation
qu'il a dû endurer vient les médecins se
montrent très prudents y compris aussi
l'entourage du ministre de l'intérieur
et tout le monde dit prudence attendons
quelques jours voire quelques semaines
merci benoît je rappelle pour ceux qui
viennent de prendre en cours ce journal
que monsieur jean pierre chevènement a
été victime d'un arrêt cardiaque à la
suite d'une anesthésie consécutif au au
début d'une opération de la vésicule
biliaire
hier et depuis 24 heures et donc dans le
coma mais benoît duquesne viens de vous
le dire
sa santé serait en phase de légère
amélioration
autre information que nous avons
développées au cours de ce journal un
avion de la swissair qui s'est abîmé
dans l'océan atlantique au large de
province canadienne de la nouvelle
écosse il y avait 2 129 personnes
adorent et il n'y a pas de survivants
dans quelques instants la météo avec
isabelle martinet à 20h50 la première de
cette nouvelle saison 98-99 d'envoyé
spécial promener en gagnant benyamine
propose deux documents importants diana
la légende
et puis un reportage à la conquête du
mont blanc demain dans les 4 vérités
gérard leclerc recevra monique veille
acquis et la secrétaire générale du snes
une dernière dernier journal de ce soir
vers zéro heure quarante de florence
duprat et puis à 20h vous retrouverez
pour cette édition demain béatrice
schönberg
bonsoir merci